皆さんこんにちははじめストです今日動画を見てもらっていうのは他でもない私が今
まで聞いてきたうちに課金した
キング食わないんだろうなぁ
はい題名の通りでございます私はじめシャツをな金に行ってきて最もお金を費やしてき
たことといえば多分
課金ですアプリへの海浜アメイズイング4角をもったいないと思う人も居ると思います
無課金でも楽しめるもんですからねアプリって
ではね課金したねー楽しいんですよ
ゲームとかカードとかに課金する気でしょうか
6使い道がなくてもういいねそれはもう趣味ですからね
趣味俺の丘では俺が使うんだよね趣味なんで訴えないのがつべこべ言われる筋合いは
ないと思ってるんですけどもうどれ
今まで行ってきてどれくらい課金したのかっていうのはちょっと見てみたいと思います
それでひょっとしたらちょっと
で羽根に帰ることもあるかもしれませんしあ
でこれからもっともっと課金するかも知れませんし1回人生でどれくらい加減している
のがちょっと見てみたいと思います
出会い校入ってゆけでこちらから見られっぽいですね
購入履歴体現したんですよなんか今まで関係者の皆でるってこと
いいいい
この僕のアカウントを使ってカー今どれくらい課金したのかっていうのはここに書いて
ありますでご覧くださいパッド3
2013年が4件2010年が39201524920162252017年307
2000数4922019年もはや66
もうこれだけで一つ分かったことがあります年々課金する会社が増えてっていま
趣味に没頭できるのであれば僕は良いと思いますだけどちょっとさっそく見ていき
ましょう
mother 2013年無料のアプリでもカウントされてるんでこれもうこれも無料
化コラムでを2013年ゼロですねキーます2013年は今どこゼロです
それで2014年ここでは作ってんだマインクラフトを買いましたね
2014年の11月にマインクラフトを買っております何かそのついでに
パズドラ兄魔法石30個かけんしてますああそれでもその次すぐを爆発15課金してる
この変化のでも始まってたんだな多分はなんかしょーもねーなんここでも干す1個買っ
てます100円を
こんなもんですよ2014年が7800円の課金です
かわいいこの時法可愛いかわいいですね
夏2015年いきましょう auto 矢部こっからパズドラで倍増
まず5000円物金で行くべしすぐまた5000円打ち込んでいく
でさらに5千円打ち込んでいくもうここで一番後鮮度やばい
ペーパーダッシュワールドにこうやってまた魔法石12個買って900円やってここね
も竿
ここで1万円課金しています
ただに5400円さらに5400円さらに5400円さらに5400円さらに5400
人と続いて2,200円
はい
ここまでが2015年です気になる金額は
27万7000380円です
うわぁ
校増えたなぁちょっとこんな感じでどんどん見ていきましょう
はいそういう理由現2016年の出費が出来ました
2016年の課金金額
4日
混ぜ6057,750円です
まぁここらへんが家と狂ってるのは何に課金したかというのを見ると
letter ね保身ドラ星のドラゴンクエストと後白猫テニス
なんとパズドラに何か定期的に課金してるのとアートランドハースストーンとか
ドラゴンプロジェクドラ風呂とかあお願いを白根ごっちゃにしてからめちゃくちゃにし
ても
これでもまた20172010初とさらに上がありますそれが見ていきましょう
ここまでがん7ですはい人たる金額あ
皆さん秘宝です私はじめたちの2017年には課金額100万円超えております
112万7150でございます
やばいなこれやばいな男銃ゲイ3月に9万円くらい課金してますねですが皆さん
これより上の土地があるです2018年なんですけどー
谷田部音やひどい時は月20万くらい課金してだから200万枚ってないと思う宮川
いかなきゃいけないかと思いますでは集計していきますよろしくお願いした
できます一番17,0001番1番街1番1番1番1番1番1番1番1番
[音楽]
me
王宮20
象嵌全10発電の換金がブーブー
それを発表いたします
去年の弾みさぞの課金額こちらです
はい
あっていただくね
やっほ
21092,800基準です
820172018年に言えることバナー松浦で傘が来て多分で補正キャラが出るまで
回してるんですよ
そこで急に何か20万とか消したりする時にあってほぼパズドラですあとなんかたまに
はまったりボスだとかで自分リアないでとかたまにハマるゲームにすぐ下記にしちゃい
ますって来ないっと僕が今で生まれてきた中のそう
外貨金額を調べます
none
出ました私はもう本当にすごい課金しておりまして今までの合計課金が変わっ
489万円670円でございます
うん
まぁでもあのいろんなアプリをやることによってね仕事につながったりもしているので
ん
ブーフの
別にいいですけどいやすごいのでもいざ通常目の前にすると実感しますねこれはヤバに
大ほぼ500万カー
ないなぁでも世の中には車に500万以上使ったり服に500万円を使ったりに
いろんな人がいるんで
いいんですけども
アプリに500万円課金したんだなんてもっと
なんかちょっと悲しい気持ちになりましたにゃんばーい
いいまあも知れて良かったですボスが毎年2倍ペースで来てる20171002010
花火の200万の2倍ペースが上がっているので今年は400万円目指します
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ